la campagne de vaccination devait
marquer un tournant et enfin permettra à
l'union européenne d'apparaître soudée
solidaire une politique d'achats groupés
de vaccins poussé notamment par le
président français pour ne pas mettre en
concurrence les différents pays membres
sauf qu'à l'aube du mois de mars les
doses tarder à arriver alors que
l'épidémie elle ne faiblit pas en
conséquence certains pays ont changé
leur fusil d'épaulé
lassé d'attendre les doses achetées par
bruxelles et qui arrivent au
compte-gouttes certains n'hésitent plus
à passer commande à des partenaires hors
de l'union européenne la hongrie avait
rapidement ouvert le bal en achetant des
vaccins spoutnik vais à moscou elle a
été imitée ces derniers jours par la
slovaquie où le premier ministre a fait
le déplacement en personne sur le tarmac
de l'aéroport pour réceptionner pas
moins de deux cent mille doses du vaccin
russe j'ai je pense qu'en respectant les
délais et les approvisionnements promis
la russie prouvera qu'elle est un
partenaire stable sur lequel nous
pouvons compter en ces temps difficiles
[Musique]
étant donné que la pandémie de kovy 19
ne fait pas attention aux questions
géopolitiques et que la protection des
vies humaines prévaut par dessus tout
nous avons jugé bon d'acheter un vaccin
russe pour que les slovaques qui le
souhaitent puissent se faire vacciner en
sous titre on devine donc une forme de
lassitude face aux réticences
européennes concernant le vaccin russe
car si l' agence européenne du
médicament examine désormais la demande
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
le spoutnik v avait d'abord été
accueillie avec prudence voire
scepticisme sur le vieux continent
certains s'opposant même à sa
distribution à cause de considérations
politiques
et voilà que de plus en plus de pays
s'intéressent au sérum russe en plus de
la hongrie et de la slovaquie la
république tchèque se dit prête à
apporter prochainement des doses de
spoutnik v et même des enquêtes
d'opinion menées en autriche en
allemagne ou encore en suisse montre une
certaine adhésion du grand public quant
à la perspective de recevoir des
injections de ce vaccin
outre l'alternative russe d'autres pays
se cherche des partenariats au delà
du vieux continent cette semaine le
chancelier autrichien et la première
ministre danoise était en israël pour y
rencontrer benyamin nétanyahou l'idée
pour les deux dirigeants européens ne
plus dépendre uniquement de bruxelles
pour les prochaines échéances
nous avons eu une réunion très
productive aujourd'hui je me tiens ici
avec deux collègues avec qui je partage
la même vision
l'accès en temps voulu aux vaccins sera
essentiel pour nos sociétés dans les
années à venir mais et nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre d'être pris au
dépourvu une nouvelle fois ces
manoeuvres ne sont en tout cas pas du
goût du secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes clément bonne
invité cette semaine sur rtl est
interrogé sur l'attitude de pays tels
que la république tchèque ou la
slovaquie
il a ainsi infirmé je cite s'il allait
chercher le vaccin chinois ou russes je
pense que ce serait grave
clément boon a même menacé ces pays
expliquant que leur stratégie du chacun
pour soi pourrait les conduire à ne pas
voir arriver les deux européennes
pourtant sur un plan juridique
rien n'interdit ses démarches mais c'est
vrai que du point de vue politique
ces dissonances européenne lézarde la
stratégie commune souhaitée par
bruxelles
déjà très décriée au début de la crise
notamment pour son manque d'action
l'union européenne peine à convaincre de
son efficacité pour répondre aux enjeux
de cette crise sans précédent on se
rappelle aussi des difficultés
rencontrées lors des négociations sur le
plan de relance de l'économie européenne
cette mort d'émile aura donc fait
ressurgir des divergences flagrante
entre les pays membres
et quand viendra l'heure du bilan rien
n'indique que ces fractures auront
disparu